ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht aber
mancher reibt sich gerade verwundert die
Augen über Bayern den zwischen dieser
Veröffentlichung am vergangenen
Wochenende berichtet die Süddeutsche
Zeitung über einen antisemitisches
Flugblatt aus den 80er Jahren und diesem
Moment
liegt gerade mal eine Woche genauso
zwischen diesem Statement meine
aufrichtige Entschuldigung gilt zuvor
dass tollen Opfern des Semester Regimes
deren Hinterbliebenen und allen
Beteiligten und der wertvollen
Erinnerungsarbeit und diesem Umfrage
Rekord der Freien Wähler im ZDF
Politbarometer ernsthaft der Mann dem
Antisemitismus Vorwürfe anhaften der sie
nur teilweise ausräumte und dessen
Krisenmanagement an disaster war dieser
Mann könnte der große Gewinner der
bayerischen Landtagswahl am 8 oktober
werden Markus Söder gefährlich die
Freien Wähler sind im Aiwanger Rausch
was ist da los in Bayern
[Applaus]
ich bin Stefan leifert leite das
ZDF-Studio in Bayern und habe in den
letzten Wochen die Affäre um den Mann
begleitet der Bayerns politische
Landkarte grad mächtig verschiebt warum
das spannend ist weil Anfang Oktober
Landtagswahlen sind und etwas passiert
ist womit wir alle nicht gerechnet
hatten Markus Söder muss plötzlich um
sein politisches Überleben kämpfen und
weil Aiwanger mit den Freien Wählern im
Bund werden will was sie in Bayern schon
sind eine feste Größe was ist also los
in Bayern ich nenne euch fünf Gründe für
den Höhenflug des Hubert Aiwanger los
geht's hier ist der erste
[Musik]
das hier war der Artikel mit dem alles
begann die Kollegen der Süddeutschen
Zeitung sind an das Flugblatt gekommen
das vor über 35 Jahren in der
Schultasche von Hubert Aiwanger gefunden
und von der Schulleitung dann auch
geahndet wurde ein Dokument der Shoa
Verherrlichung voller Gewalt Fantasien
und NS Vokabular fast alles an den
Recherchen über aiwangers zweifelhafte
Umtriebe in der Jugend war korrekt nur
an einer Stelle vielleicht sogar der
wichtigsten blieb eine Lücke in der
Beweiskette das Hubert Aiwanger Autor
des pamphlets war konnte die SZ nicht
wasserdicht belegen ja und so meldete
sich dann Hubert Bruder Helmut und
bekannte sich dazu das Blatt verfasst zu
haben und plötzlich war der Platz für
die Behauptung nicht die ergebnisoffene
Recherche habe die Zeitung getrieben
sondern der Wille einwanger vom Sockel
zu stoßen der werdende Ton in dem der
Text der Süddeutschen erschienen
verstärkte diesen Eindruck ebenso der
Zeitpunkt der Veröffentlichung kurz vor
der Landtagswahl Medienkritiker
Niggemeier schreibt die Geschichte sei
problematisch weil sie nicht nüchtern
über die Vorwürfe berichtet sondern all
jenen Munition gibt die ihr unterstellen
eine Agenda zu haben Aiwanger kurz vor
der Wahl wegzuschreiben die
Berichterstattung der Süddeutschen
Zeitung ist durchaus auch umstritten da
gibt es Leute die sagen das ist im
Grunde so eine Art verdachtsbericht
Erstattung und damit war neben den
Vorwürfen die sich an Hubert Aiwanger
richten plötzlich eine zweite Geschichte
im Raum die von den Medien die nicht
sauber arbeiten und mehr an ihre eigene
these Glauben als an das Ergebnis der
Recherche auch Markus Söder gelernter
Journalist übrigens hat sie übernommen
um seine Entscheidung zu untermauern an
Hubert Aiwanger festzuhalten ich glaube
das ist sehr viele Bürger gibt die auch
ein bisschen kritisch sind wieder Ungarn
ist Journalismus mit vielen Themen ist
ich würde das sogar als ein Teil der
gesamten Debatte jetzt hier betrachten
die Geschichte scheint ja auch so haben
wir es gelesen ich glaube sogar im
Spiegel auch anderen Medien angeboten
worden zu sein die haben es aber nicht
abge druckt weil sie offensichtlich das
nicht als so stark empfunden haben und
damit wären wir bei Grund 2 für den
einwanger Hype die Opfer erzählung
[Musik]
seit Beginn der Affäre wird Hubert
Aiwanger wo immer er hinkommt seinen
Auftritten gefeiert wie so ein Kämpfer
der siegreich aus der Schlacht
zurückkehrt so sah die Schlange aus die
sich morgens vor dem Zelt am gillamos
seinem großen Volksfest bildete in dem
Stunden später Hubert Aiwanger reden
sollte Hubert Aiwanger macht gerade voll
auf Volkstribun der Skandal hat ihm eine
nie dagewesene mediale Sichtbarkeit
verpasst und seine Fans verehren ihn
seit der flugblattaffäre sogar noch mehr
ich habe mein kleines Video mitgebracht
[Applaus]
ernsthaft jetzt ja Hubert awanger hat es
geschafft mit der Erzählung von sich als
Opfer einer Kampagne die rein hinter
sich zu schließen hierher das Opfer da
die Medien die ihn angeblich politisch
vernichten wollen
von langer Hand geplant in Aiblinger
fertig zu machen mit dem Ziel die Freien
Wähler zu schwächen eventuell sogar die
Grünen in die Landesregierung zu bringen
das ist nicht unser Ziel hier wurde
versucht die Wahl gezielt zu
beeinflussen das ist eine Schweinerei
meine Damen und Herren noch bevor sich
Aiwanger entschuldigt sich erklärt hat
sich zu den Vorwürfen ausführlich
geäußert hat war da diese Erzählung im
Raum was ich da aus diesem Satz höre ist
das was man unter einer opfertäter
umkämpfe steht dass also jetzt versucht
wird die Opfer zu Tätern zu machen aber
wieso funktioniert er diese Täter Opfer
Umkehr eigentlich und jetzt kommt der
Clou weil Aiwanger sich bewusst oder
unterbewusst einer Methode bediente die
wir von erraten Donald Trump kennen
[Musik]
deswegen einfach so ein gutes Beispiel
ist es tut mir auch leid für ihn weil es
einfach so ein gutes Beispiel weil er
etwas gemacht hat was natürlich aus dem
Playbook von Donald Trump stammt nicht
nur hat er sofort gesagt ich bin das
Opfer und sondern er hat auch gesagt
eigentlich bin nicht ich das Opfer es
geht eigentlich nicht gegen mich es geht
gegen euch gegen die normalen Menschen
klar einfacher ist kein Trump ist zum
bewaffneten Aufstand würde der Mann aus
Niederbayern vermutlich nicht aufrufen
aber manche Methode hat der freie
wählerchef einfach übernommen das
Feindbild Elite z.B und die
Gleichsetzung seiner Person mit der
sogenannten normalen Bevölkerung auch
ich habe in meiner Jugend Scheiß
gemacht aber meine Damen und Herren
hier wurde von langer Hand geplant in
Aiblinger fertig zu machen habt ihr es
gehört der Aiwanger das ist aiwangers
Chiffre für den einfachen Bürger soll
heißen ein Angriff auf Hubert Aiwanger
ist immer auch ein Angriff auf alle
Freien Wähler auf alle Aiwanger Anhänger
eigentlich auf alle normalen Bürger
sollten geschwächt werden
es war ein schmutziges Wort Wert von dem
sich viele noch werden distanzieren
müssen und die Parteifunktionäre haben
das Spiel einfach mitgespielt kritiklose
Aiwanger Verteidigung klingt so
und wir stehen hinter dir wenn von
hinten mit Dreck geworden
hat den Kampfgeist der Freien Wähler
erst so richtig geweckt der Tabubruch
Antisemitismus Vorwürfe in eine
Schmutzkampagne umzudeuten statt sie
aufzuklären er zahlt sich aus
einfacher schlägt aus der Affäre Profit
macht aus Defensive Angriff aus einem
Tabu ein Bierzelt Schlager
aber wenn das zu einem positiven
Wahlerfolg führt ein solches Blatt dann
irritiert mich das in höchstem Maße und
zeigt natürlich dass offensichtlich was
ich nicht gedacht hätte mit der
Aufarbeitung der Geschichte des
Nationalsozialismus doch mehr im Algen
ist als viele vermuten und so klappt
eine riesige Kluft zwischen der Empörung
außerhalb der Bierzelte und der
Solidarisierung mit Aiwanger dort drin
ist
dann ist es
so unmöglich weil es einer von den
besten Politiker in Bayern
obwohl dass ich noch nie gewählt habe
aber wir werden jetzt fehlen ohne Hubert
wahrscheinlich nie gehen
nein in Bayern ist einfach Hubert
eiwanger ist einfach die Freien Wähler
hat seine Partei und das schon lange vor
der flugblattaffäre mit ganz simplen
Gegensätzen ideologisiert statt gegen
Land oben gegen unten liberale gegen
konservative abgehobene Politiker Elite
gegen den normalen Bürger das ist der
Trump Sound bei seinem demo-auftritt
gegen das heizungsgesetz in Erding trieb
Aiwanger ist mit dieser Rhetorik auf die
Spitze als sie ist der Punkt wo endlich
die schweige in die große Mehrheit
dieses Landes sich die Demokratie wieder
zurückholen muss und denen in Berlin
sagen ihr habt wohl den Arsch offen oben
meine Damen und Herren Robert Aiwanger
bekannt den Applaus der 13.000 in Erding
einer bekam ihn nicht und das war Markus
Söder der wurde ausgebucht und damit
wären wir beim vierten Grund für den
einwanger Höhenflug der söderfaktor
[Musik]
für Markus Söder war die Affäre eiwanger
ein politischer Gau denn sie hat ihm ein
Dilemma gebracht der CSU-Chef musste nun
den Schiedsrichter geben und dabei
überall Wanger Schicksal entscheiden
entlassen oder belassen eine Wahl
zwischen Pest und Cholera so da konnte
eigentlich nur verlieren entweder seinen
Koalitionspartner oder die Sympathien
aller die einwangers Verhalten in der
flugplatzaffäre für unwürdig und
geschichts Vergessenheit halten und der
gesamtablegung
dass kein Beweis vorliegt dass die Sache
35 Jahre her ist und das seitdem nichts
Vergleichbares vorgefallen ist wäre eine
Entlassung aus dem Amt aus meiner Sicht
nicht verhältnismäßig Söder entschied
also auf Freispruch na gut also mit so
ein bisschen Bewährung das Hubert
Aiwanger war dann arbeitet verloren
gegangenes Vertrauen zurückzugewinnen so
dass er auch Gespräche mit jüdischen
Gemeinden suchen sollte eigentlich
wollte Söder in der Affäre den Chef
Aufklärer geben er verlangte von
Aiwanger Reue zweifelsfreie Aufklärung
und stellte 25 fragen was er bekam war
eine später entschuldigung ich beruhigt
so tiefst wenn ich durch mein Verhalten
in Bezug auf das in Rede stehende
Pamphlet Gefühle verletzt habe
schwammige Antworten und vor allem aber
lauter Erinnerungslücken hier so sah der
Antwort Katalog auf das entzieht sich
meiner Kenntnis ist mir nicht bekannt
daran kann ich mich nicht mehr erinnern
ist mir nicht meine Erinnerung
hoffentlich erinnert sich der Mann
zumindest daran wie er heißt dass ich
Söder trotz dieser nicht antworten gegen
eine Entlassung entschied macht so das
selbstgebaute Sackgasse sichtbar sein
Schicksal ist an das von Hubert aanger
gekettet alle anderen Parteien zum
Gegner erklärt fällt Söder jetzt in den
Graben den er mit seiner Anti Ampel
Rhetorik selbst geschaufelt hat zu
Aiwanger gibt es für Söder keine
Alternative und sind bei einer wir
damals gesagt wir machen nicht
Schwarz-Grün wir machen jetzt auch nicht
schwarz grün die letzten Umfragen sind
verheerend für die CSU
36%, das wäre eine historische
Katastrophe und die Freien Wähler
erleben ein nie da gewesenen Höhenflug
und das alles kurz vor der Landtagswahl
bei der die CSU um ihre deutsche
Sonderrolle kämpft Markus Söder um seine
politische Zukunft und auch seine
Ambitionen auf die Kanzlerkandidatur die
CSU und das erleben wir in München
tagtäglich ist so nervös wie lange nicht
es Humor angesichts des Aufstiegs der
Freien Wähler das so
Solidarisierung drin das war eine sehr
auffüllende Wochen die letzten zwei auch
für die Bayern und deswegen gab es die
Solidarität aber ich glaube das wird
sich auch in den nächsten Wochen
möglicherweise wieder verändern für uns
ist sicher noch ein bisschen Luft nach
oben drin in anderen Umfragen liegen wir
deutlich drüber aber die sind alles nur
im Moment Aufnahmen ja kann sich
vielleicht und wenn nicht dann hätte
Deutschlands Parteien Landschaft eine
neue Größe und hier Union ein Problem
und dann damit sind wir bei Grund 5 für
den einwanger Rausch
[Musik]
in Bayern waren die Freien Wähler für
die CSU schon immer Konkurrenz und Dorn
im Auge sie sind sich ähnlich und genau
deswegen in tiefer Abneigung verbunden
sowieso da und aanger auch ganz
persönlich mit alwanger rücken die
Freien Wähler nun nach rechts Aiwanger
mobilisiert mit Abneigung gegen den
Politikbetrieb Schütze ziemlich jedes
Risotto gegen die da oben schöpft aus
dem riesigen Potential der unzufriedenen
die Freien Wähler scheinen den Raum
zwischen CSU und AFD zu besetzen genau
da wo die CSU eigentlich auch sein will
die AFD wusste in der eiwanger-affäre
nicht so richtig wohin mit sich aber am
Ende fand einfacher in der AFD die
einzige Partei die auf seiner Seite
steht ich halte es für völlig unerhört
dass gerade die angeblich so toleranten
Grünen und SPD sich damit nicht
zufrieden geben wollen und einem
Menschen nicht zugestehen wollen dass
Sie sich in 35 Jahren vielleicht
weiterentwickelt hat auch mal vielleicht
Fehler im Leben gemacht hat aber dass er
jetzt eben auch in anderer Mensch ist
die Freien Wähler kommen eigentlich aus
der Mitte keine Frage aber Aiwanger
führt sie nun auf diesen schmalen Grad
zwischen CSU und AFD zwischen
elitenverachtung einerseits aber
gemäßigteren tönen als die der AFD
andererseits das eiwanger damit auch im
afd-reservoir Fischen will macht diese
richtig nervös Hubert Aiwanger hat sich
das ja auf die Fahne geschrieben dass er
unsere unsere Wählerstimmen der AFD
abjagen möchte die Wähler sind in Bayern
derzeit dabei zu sondieren wollen Sie
wirklich Aiwanger werden die Schein
Opposition oder gehen sie doch zum
Original zu der Alternative für
Deutschland es wird eng im rechten
Parteienspektrum Bayerns eiwanger
jedenfalls hat überhaupt keine
Berührungsängste ich glaube das ist kein
Becken eine Partei gibt dass sie sich
selber in Anspruch nehmen kann und
natürlich will ich fische von anderen
Parteien zurückholen vor allem in die
demokratische Mitte zurückholen eine
Alternative rechts von der CSU aber
nicht extrem Wähler der AFD anlocken
ohne die AFD zu kopieren das ist die
Nische die Aiwanger besetzen will die
Freien Wähler würden auf keinen Fall den
Klimawandel leugnen wollen auch
klimapolitische Maßnahmen durchsetzen
sie wollen nicht die EU auflösen und sie
sind einfach keine rechtspopulistische
bis zum Teil auch rechtsradikale Partei
als Koalitionspartner bleiben sie der
CSU also erhalten unter das
anti-extremistengebot mit dem die CSU
gerade Bayern plakatiert fällt die
einwangerpartei nicht wir wollen mit
rechtsradikalen Narren und Extremisten
nichts zu tun haben und trotzdem hat die
CSU ein Problem rechts von ihr sollte
nie eine demokratische legitimierte
Partei Platz haben das galt eigentlich
immer das ist ein Diktum von CSU über
Vater Franz Josef Strauß das eigentlich
bis heute auch gilt Eingang als Freie
Wähler besetzen nun genau diesen Raum
Markus Söder hat das Schicksal sein
Partei also an die Partei gekettet die
an den Grundfesten der CSU rührt nach
der aiwangeraffäre mehr denn je also bei
den Wahlen in Bayern steht viel auf dem
Spiel für die CSU ihre Vormachtstellung
in Bayern für Markus Söder seine
politische Zukunft und die Chancen auf
Kanzlerkandidatur und Aiwanger wird
sehen ob sein Höhenflug nur Strohfeuer
oder Flächenbrand wird denn Bayern soll
für Aiwanger nur der Anfang sein sein
Traum bleibt der Bundestag wir bleiben
dran bleibt ihr es auch am besten auf
diesem Kanal und mit einem Abo servus